hi this is pressure Locker a census
taker visits the home of a mathematician
and asked for the ages of his children
the mathematician offers up a riddle if
you add up the ages of my three children
you get my house number and if you
multiply the ages you get the results 72
this census taker thinks about it and
replies he still doesn't know the ages
of the children the mathematician says
of course not I forgot to mention my
oldest child loves chocolate chip
cookies
suddenly the census taker says he gets
it and he writes down the three ages of
the children what are the ages of the
children give this puzzle a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution like any good puzzle you
have to deduce some of the details from
the story first you have to deduce that
the census taker knows the house number
of the mathematician this is a census
taker who should know the address and
he's also visiting the mathematician at
his home the other detail which is a
little more controversial but is
generally common sense is that you have
to conclude the mathematician has an
oldest child with a distinct age so not
twins and not to children's that are
born almost to your part this comes from
the detail where the mathematician says
his oldest child loves chocolate chip
cookies this implies the mathematician
does not have two oldest children who
are twins
because you wouldn't generally refer to
twins as being the oldest child even
though one of the children is probably
older by a few minutes and you could
also have a child who's born say 9 to 12
months apart and they could possibly be
the same age even though they're not
exactly born in the same you know
they're not twins but commonly this
doesn't happen so in this story we're
going to say the mathematician has an
oldest child with a distinct age and
that's going to give the census taker
the detail he needs so how can the
census taker figure this out the
mathematician says the three children
have a product of their ages of 72 we
can factor 72 into the primes 2 times 2
times 2 times 3 times 3 there are only a
few prime factors and so when we
consider the way that you could get 3
different ages to multiply to be 70
- they're actually only 12 different
possibilities these are written in
increasing order you could have won 172
one 236 one 324 one 418 one 612 189 to
218 2 3 12 to 4 9 to 6 6 3 3 8 or 3 4 6
the census taker could work out the sum
of the three ages to get these results
so now here's what goes through the
census taker spine the mathematician
says if you add up the three ages you
get the house number so if the house
number was anything besides 14 this
census taker would uniquely be able to
identify the three ages of the children
if the house number was 22 for example
the census taker would know the children
have to be age to 2 and 18 or if thus if
the house number was 15 the census taker
would know the ages would have to be 249
because there's no other way you could
get to that sum so when the census taker
says he's tried to work it out but he
still can't figure it out
knowing the house number that means the
house number has to be 14
so the census taker is trying to figure
out whether the three kids our age - 6 +
6 or 3 3 + 8 and this is where the
detail that the oldest child loves
chocolate chip cookies comes into play
the oldest child implies there's one old
with one child who has a distinct age
that's the oldest child so we can rule
out the possibility of 2 6 + 6 and that
means the answer is 3 3 + 8 did you
figure it out thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Walker and if you liked this video
please check out my books there links in
the video description